bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous la campagne qui n'a pas débuté
officiellement j'en parlais avec mon
invité précédent pour 2022 et déjà lexsi
ça part dans tous les sens avec cette
séquence d'hier notamment
oui on voit très bien que avec cette
séquence comme vous dites ou où les
policiers ont compris l'agenda politique
finalement avec cette manifestation
devant l'assemblée nationale la ligne d
eau a dû être tracée entre ceux qui
étaient là ce qui n'était pas là comment
on se positionnait par rapport aux
revendications des syndicats policiers
il n'est pas question bien sûr de tous
les policiers mais là des syndicats
policiers
et on a vu à peu près tout le monde qui
a été obligé de prendre position d'une
façon ou d'une autre plus ou moins
adroitement on a vu olivier faure se
prendre les pieds dans le tapis
eric jadot qui a du mal à expliquer
pourquoi ils étaient là et puis marine
le pen qui n'étaient pas là et qui a
finalement dit au loin tout le soutien
qu'elle donnait bien sûr aux syndicats
policiers dans leurs démarches avec une
question fondamentale dans ce dans ses
revendications quelle est la place de la
police quelle est la place de la
séparation des pouvoirs dans la
construction démocratique qu'est la
république française et je crois qu'on
n'a pas assez parlé finalement de
constitutionnalité et beaucoup de
revendications sans peser là
l'importance de ces revendications et
aujourd'hui on a vu beaucoup de
rétropédalage ou bien une surenchère
parce que clairement la campagne a
commencé comme vous venez de le dire de
manière tout à fait informelle et sur le
thème de la sécurité poussés par les
syndicats de police qui manifestaient
hier en quelque sorte
alexis folin du pain bénit quand même
pour le hand on le sait la sécurité est
l'un des thèmes de prédilection oui
alors c'est clair que pour marine le pen
elle n'avait pas besoin d'être là quand
on voit les sondages on sait déjà que un
fort pourcentage de membres des forces
de l'ordre vote déjà ou sont
sympathisants des idées de marine le pen
donc pour elle elle a simplement à
compter ses troupes
il ya quelque chose là aussi d'une
dérive politique d'art d'un grand
service de l'état le service de la
police nationale qui devient politique
d'une certaine façon
attention à ce que ça ne devienne pas
une police politique qui se veut au
service
parti ou d'un gouvernement la police est
là pour protéger les citoyens et pas l
inverse et on a vu effectivement des
syndicats des syndicalistes policiers
vouloir attaquer la justice en disant
que les décisions de justice n'était pas
juste comme elle devait être et que la
police devait avoir plus de pouvoir or
la séparation des pouvoirs elle est
extrêmement importante pour l'équilibré
des pouvoirs pour l' équilibre
démocratique et il fallait le rappeler
et puis marine le pen elle n'était pas
parmi les manifestants mais on a vu
d'autres personnalités politiques qui
étaient présentes comme eric zemmour
comme jean lassalle comme philippe de
villiers qui pourrait faire de l'ombre à
marine le pen si jamais il décidait de
lancer une candidature un peu surprise
en lisant finalement marine le pen elle
est là depuis toujours elle a toujours
eu les mêmes idées on la connaît mais
elle fait un peu partie du système on
sait que l a déjà fait 2017
alors si et ont créé un candidat issu du
parent ou un triumvirat avec ces trois
là par exemple qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer donc elle a aussi peur marine le
pen d'être dépassé peut-être parce à
droite tous d'être ringardisé entre
guillemets par une nouvelle garde
politique même si eric zemmour comme
jean lassalle ou philippe de villiers ne
sont pas des perdreaux de l'année
alors parmi les politiques évidemment
gérald darmanin présence très
commentaire une fois n'est pas coutume
le ministre de l'intérieur au milieu
d'une manifestation de policiers c'était
quoi une faute politique s'y rendre je
crois que c'était une faute politique
une faute communicationnel un fiasco de
toute façon on a vu gérald darmanin et
le préfet l'allemand lui est assez
rapidement par les manifestants et
évidemment comment voulez vous qu'un
ministre critiqué pour ses prises de
position sa politique par les syndicats
qui sont dans la rue se retrouve avec
eux pensant retourner la situation est
en quelque sorte raccrocher les wagons
avec la base c'est ridicule ça ne s'est
jamais vu c'était inédit
tout le monde aurait dû d'ailleurs dire
à gérald darmanin n'y va pas c'est un
piège où c'est une grave erreur
politique
il a voulu essayer il l'a fait ça a été
un fiasco
il ne fallait pas en attendre autre
chose et voilà tout est dit on ne peut
pas quand on est ministre et critiqué
pour son action manifester avec les
manifestants qui vous critiquent pour
votre action
ça paraît être une base de la politique
telle qu'elle est et puis gérald
darmanin n'est pas en reste d'ailleurs
pour recevoir les syndicats à beauvau et
parler autour d'une table plutôt que
d'être là
lors des revendications dans la rue pour
compter les troupes comptait la force
bien sûr de ces syndicats donc le
dialogue existe évidemment entre le
ministre et les syndicalistes
donc cette mise en scène
communicationnel qui est vraiment là la
signature de la république en marché de
ce gouvernement où toutes les
communications avant d'être politique et
réfléchie a été une fois de plus un
fiasco total
gérald darmanin et dupond moretti un
trouve s'affrontent entre guillemets sur
ces thèmes sécurité police justice ce
bras de fer entre ces deux ministères
est ce qu'il est de nature à entretenir
encore un petit peu plus la confusion
que l'on reproche parfois emmanuel
macron sur cette ligne justement
sécuritaire oui complètement
on a vu alors oui c'était une des
critiques bien sûr des syndicats
policiers de de pointer du doigt la
justice trop laxistes qui ne connaît pas
le métier qui ne connaît pas la rue qui
ne connaît pas la violence à laquelle on
va faire les policiers et donc il
fallait que deux ministres finalement
s'affrontent pour défendre chacun leur
ministère en disant moi je fais très
bien mon travail et vous aussi chers
collègues vous faites très bien votre
travail et police et justice sont dans
la même barque ce sont deux services
régaliens extrêmement important pour la
corée la cohésion dans la société pour
la sécurité de tous les citoyens donc le
fait de se faire la guerre c'est un très
mauvais signe à la fois pour la
démocratie
ça voudrait dire qu'un pouvoir voudrait
prendre le pas sur un autre est donc
déséquilibré
toute cette barque qui prend déjà
beaucoup l'eau donc la mise en scène de
deux ministres qui s'affrontent c'est
aussi une réponse très politique parce
que eric dupond-moretti garde des sceaux
est entré en campagne dans la région
nord pour faire de l'ombre à xavier
bertrand et à marine le pen également
parce qu'il était ministre de médiatique
on va dire donc c'est une façon de saper
un peu de 2,7 aura médiatique d'eric
dupond-moretti de le ramener à son rôle
de ministre de voir comment il défend
son ministère comment ils se
positionnent par rapport à cette
question de la sécurité est encore une
fois c'est en même temps macro nist qui
ne fonctionne pas qui est à un surplace
permanent et un à peu près de 2 fait de
se rattraper aux branches et de dire
tout et son contraire en permanence le
en même temps sur beaucoup de sujets ça
ne fonctionne pas que ce soit sur
l'immigration la sécurité
tous les grands sujets l'économie
également
on voit que ça peut marcher en campagne
puisque c'est des promesses mais quand
on est au pouvoir on ne peut pas faire
du en même temps merci beaucoup alexis
poulain d'avoir été avec nous en direct